[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today hi Judy
welcome to the show hi Rachel hi John
thanks for having me on absolutely how
can we help well I've been specifically
waiting for John on this one oh John
here you go pitches to you so um my
husband and I so I'm like the budgeter
and in charge of the finances I pay all
the bills out of our joint account all
that I've been listening to ramsy for
years I'm super no dead all of that kind
of stuff um we did have some debt we
paid down to $600 almost done but then
uh within the last month I found out
that my husband has actually committed
what the term is uh it's Financial
infidelity um to to the tune of
$50,000 oh wow um I'm sorry
j yeah um the reason I'm not um like in
tears it's because I've already done all
that um and I so what happened was was
um I found out we have meetings about
money and um I recently heard some
advice that instead of just having
meetings we should press I should press
to see all of the accounts like what are
the statements let me see the you know
show me your phone all that kind of
thing and he had been avoiding that and
now I know it's because um there were
balances that I did not know about um so
was what was he spending that money on
hun so I I now have the PCO to all to
everything and it was it was just
groceries and gas and kids need this it
was there was nothing extravagant it's
just he was spending more than he was
making and it's s I'm stay home mom so
we just didn't have the income so he had
run up credit cards got a $177,000
personal loan to pay them off last year
and then ran them up ran it up again to
$24,000 another
$24,000 loan this year uh just two
months ago Judy have you seen those
statements yes I've seen everything now
I've seen I I got his credit report um
I've got um we have we have this The
Joint banking account but we each have a
checking um so I I have his lo I have
his passwords I have everything well I
here what I'm here's what I'm getting at
it's very it happens it there's no
question it happens yeah
$50,000 is a lot of money yeah to hide
it's a lot yeah and it's very rare that
the nickel and diming of groceries here
soccer uniform
here it doesn't include a hotel room
here a trip away here alcohol or
gambling over here I've pulled every
single statement okay and he's he's so
the largest things are he's $250 he's
loan to his sister or you know something
like that there's nothing I've asked him
down to $60 $25 there's a $10 charge
what is this there's interest there's
late fees he hasn't been paying them on
time so there's hundreds of dollars of
interest and late fees um on on all of
the cards and I think what what hurts me
the most is that he I'm always talking
about money and I thought we were
together um but we were not and he he
his explanation is that well he doesn't
really have an explanation he's very
humble he told me he's ashamed he told
me he's embarrassed right he's sorry um
he feels like he wasn't able to provide
for us there really isn't anything I
like I said I've combed through I've
printed statements I've highlighted I've
asked about everything I've added things
up and he just was swiping his card he
just we just didn't have the money okay
so I I'm I we have we start FP today
because I I push for that okay because I
you know mindset wise I feel like we're
just not we weren't together so what's
your question H how can I help well
something must have happened for this
connection like what what do I do
emotionally towards him I know there's
the money part but there's also the
relationship part sure so here here's
what's here's what's real important you
mentioned it you kind of flew over it
and I think this is where you have to
start okay and this is not a traditional
infidelity
advice when somebody cheats on you
whether with another person whether with
money whether with any number of things
I think you can cheat on your wife with
a golf course I think you cheat on your
wife with work right with the office I
think you can cheat on your wife with a
whole bunch of stuff or cheat on your
husband with a whole bunch of stuff I
think um honestly we so narrowly Define
ID it into the act of some sort of
sexual act I think infidelity is way
bigger than that
but we often focus on that thing and
that's what the Hollywood movies are
made of and that's what the big oh my
gosh and you talk to your friends I
think there's another thing that is more
um catastrophic and that is
this you missed
it and you don't trust you
anymore you don't trust the ground you
walk on you don't trust the cereal
you're eating you don't trust your own
your own radar
system and that I think is often as much
if not more disorienting than the actual
Act of infidelity because when he sat
down and explained it to you and you
went through every single thing his
story actually makes
sense he was a grown man who was ashamed
that he couldn't provide for his kids
and he just punted reality until it hit
him in the mouth I wouldn't advise that
but that story is plausible
what's scary for you is the sidewalk you
walk on which is I can at least trust me
you don't trust you
anymore and so I think you start this
process a with here's the four or five
things I need on a daily basis so that I
can begin to rebuild trust your marriage
as you knew it was over y'all are
building something completely new honey
I need these four or five things every
single day and you get to decide what
those are and he gets to decide whether
he's in or out but more importantly I
want you to go talk to a professional
counselor in fact stay on the line I'm
going to hook you up with 3 months with
my friends at better
help you have to start learning to trust
you again cuz you're not crazy and right
now you feel like you've lost in the
wind hang on we'll get you hooked up
with some professional licensed
therapist